Je trouve ça ouf quand même qu'on n'ait toujours pas réussi à inventer l'hoverboard
Pas ouf, mais plutôt décevant
Tu sais un petit peu comme quand tu pensais que le père Noël existait et que tu apprends qu'il n'existe pas
Tu t'en doutais, mais tu es quand même déçu.
du coup c'est une sorte de fantasme, c'est un truc qu'on essaie d'atteindre
D'ailleurs, est-ce qu'il faut l'atteindre?
est-ce que l'hoverboard doit exister?
[Générique]
Marty et Doc sont censés revenir aujourd'hui mais contrairement à ce qu'avance la
science-fiction, on a toujours pas d'hoverboard. Pourtant tu as tellement d'entreprises qui ont essayé.
Genre par exemple t'as ça… T'as ça…
T'as ça…
Et t'as même des entreprises qui n'ont pas du tout essayé mais qui ont quand même
appelé ça hoverboard
En fait c'est devenu un objectif pour l'humanité
et on est tellement blasé de ne pas avoir réussi à le faire qu'on arrive à faire des fausses pubs
s'il te plaît
Est-ce que le plus gros échec c'est pas quand t'es obligé de te mentir à toi-même ?
Mais je comprends tu vois, c'est
important d'avoir un objectif même
à l'échelle de l'humanité, enfin surtout
à l'échelle de l'humanité
c'est bon pour le progrès
Le progrès. C'est une idée récente ça en plus
ça date de Descartes, Pascal, Gallilé
genre avant les gens croyaient en la répétition
genre tout ce qui était nouveau, c'était considéré comme décadant
Tu me diras, il y a toujours des gens qui pensent comme ça aujourd'hui
Bon après quand je parle de progrès
je parle de la transformation qui nous amène
d'un état à du plus, donc on parle de quantité
ou alors à du mieux, on parle de qualité
Clairement dans "retour vers le futur 2" on va nous présenter par exemple des films en hologramme
ce qui a priori est du progrès
et du pepsi perfect, ce qui a priori ne l'est pas
après faut aussi garder en tête que
le progrès n'est pas nécessairement positif,
par exemple des fois on va vouloir régler un problème avec le progrès
alors qu'en fait on va juste le déplacer
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'effet rebond
par exemple avec l'explosion de
l'ordinateur et du digital
on pensait que ça allait être la fin du papier
alors qu'en fait la consommation de papier a augmenté
parce que les gens, les particuliers s'équipent en imprimante
et le progrès c'est un truc que globalement on cherche tous
en fait ça vient d'une idée un peu naïve qui dit que
si on est malheureux c'est parce qu'on vit dans la misère
et que si on vivait dans l'abondance
on serait plus heureux.
Et pour plein de penseurs, de Hugo à Marx, le malheur du monde venait de la misère
et du coup la solution c'était la
technique
Bon, globalement à part Dan Bilzerian qui a l'air très heureux
et dont on reparlera une prochaine fois
cette idée c'est un petit peu n'importe quoi
même si j'avoue que je préfère être malheureux avec un Ipod qu'un lecteur CD.
Mais là avec l'hoverboard on est allé trop loin
genre on a cru qu'on allait tacler un truc comme la gravité aussi facilement ?
Mais je vais vous dire,
parfois je me dis que c'est peut-être pas un mal
déjà parce que ça redonne de la valeur à l'innovation.
Quand tu vois le nombre de ceux qui ont
été prévus par "Retour vers le futur"
et réalisés
c'est ouf !
Et tout le monde s'en tape.
Tout le monde s'en tape !
Les gens pensent que ça tombe du ciel, que c'est normal
Il y a Diderot qui dit une phrase super cool là-dessus d'ailleurs:
En fait, ça redonne pas de la valeur qu'à l'innovation,
ça donne de la valeur à la science quoi?
Rien n'est acquis.
Tu sais les scientifiques,
c'est pas des chasseurs cueilleurs qui partent et qui reviennent avec une innovation.
Et en plus, le fait de ne pas avoir réussi à faire l'hoverboard
ça va nous donner un truc pour nous surpasser
si t'as pas d'objectif et que t'as pas de but
c'est très difficile d'évaluer comment t'avances
et c'est même très facile de ne pas avancer du tout
et c'est super intéressant dans un film
sur le voyage temporel
que l'on retienne quand même l'hoverboard
parce que les deux sont très liés
pour les deux en fait c'est un truc sur lesquels on fantasme
pour défier notre condition mortelle,
alors qu'en fait c'est inatteignable.
J'crois...
Après comme je l'ai dit il y a plein de trucs qu'on a réussi à réaliser,
par exemple dans le film à un moment ils arrivent avec une pizza déshydratée
qu'ils transforment en pizza normale.
Mec, nous on fait mieux !
On imprime des pizzas  !
Ca personne n'en parle
tout le monde fait une fixette sur l'hoverboard,
alors qu'on a les skates qui sont déjà très bien
et en plus si l'hoverboard sort, 90% des gens ne sauront pas en faire
ça... ça a aucun sens.
En fait si ça en a un,
c'est parce qu'on est ambitieux.
C'est ça que nous montre cet hoverboard en fait
et c'est pourquoi c'est la seule chose qu'on retient de ce film en terme de progrès
l'humanité est ambitieuse, et elle aura toujours besoin d'un hoverboard.
Ce sera peut-être pas l'hoverboard en tant que tel, mais ça sera un objet qui nous fait rêver,
qui est difficilement réalisable et qui nous rappelle du coup tout le terrain
qui nous reste à conquérir.
Alors, je veux bien que l'hoverboard existe, il n'y a pas de soucis,
mais d'ici là il va falloir qu'on trouve un objectif tout aussi cool
qui est du coup moins réalisable, mais plus réalisable qu'une Delorean qui voyage dans le passé.
Nan parce que ça c'est chaud quand même.
j'espère que t'as kiffé, n'hésite pas à t'abonner pour ne rater aucun épisode
et à balancer tes réflexions en commentaire, parce que ça c'était juste la mienne.
L'art a donné à la science un défi, et c'est bien la seule à pouvoir encore le faire
J'vous envoie du love et de la peace !
Ciao